hier soir dans le jt de tf1 avec la
connerie recevez un énième hommes
politiques en costard cravate ah bah non
c'était juste stromae ça fait comme
geagea qui faisait son grand retour
après sept ans d'absence bonsoir merci
beaucoup d'être là bonsoir un clair
merci a vous de me recevoir bon ce qui
est sûr c'est que le belge aime créer la
surprise sur les plateaux comme en 2013
où il avait débarqué au grand journal
avec son brushing façon valérie bénaïm
pour faire un duo avec lui-même
et donc cette fois encore il a voulu
marquer les esprits en pleine interview
au détour d'une question dans vos
chansons vous parlez aussi beaucoup de
solitude est ce que la musique vous a
aidé à vous en libérer j'ai parfois eu
des pensées suicidaires et j'en suis
fier on croit parfois que c'est la seule
manière de les faire taire en demande
quand même s'il n'a pas été inspiré par
patrick fiori et son joli timbre de voix
sur 20
et
si certains en grappe qui fait la
surprise de stromae comme bruno le maire
quelle performance à la fin ce n'est
visiblement pas le cas du journal
libération qui dénonce une opération
marketing mais reprenez-vous
l'indignation du journal
[Musique]
voilà c'est vrai que ça fait énormément
parler la prestation de stromae tiens
d'ailleurs sur vous sur votre côté pmp
paul bernard montiel qui réagit très
sympa bernard très méritée pour mathieu
bravo mais ça reste est
ce que vous comprenez l'indignation du
monde à libération on va démarrer par la
question et comprenez vous ou
l'indignation du journal libération on
va démarrer par allez raymond non moi je
comprends pas la négation puisque tf1
enfin un gros coup ils font ni astro
mike somail qui fait un gros coup lui
aussi en allant sur terre ils adorent
vrai que c'était perturbant de voir ça
parce que tu t'es demandait une fraction
de seconde est-ce que ça à sa place au
journal de tf1 oui finalement ça à sa
place parce que c'est pas que le coc
vide c'est pas que des morts c'est pas
que des drames le journal de tf1 c'est
aussi bien c'est la grande messe mois
pour moi c'est un bon retour il a bien
chanté c'est un truc qu'on n'avait
jamais vu aussi pour moi j'aime bien moi
j'aime bien les gens qui prennent des
risques
on n'avait jamais vu c'est un risque et
libération chebah saas fee pisse froid
quand même de critiquer un truc comme ça
mais on ne sait pas elle n'allait pas
critiquer ça il n'y a pas ni rien de
critiquable là dedans stromae c'est un
vrai artiste s'est il fait partie des
dés que vous avez vrai coup de coeur
merci j'ai eu à 3,10 qui fait pep pisse
froid mais c'est une honte ce qui s'est
passé pourquoi cet homme ce chanteur qui
revient pour faire sa promotion a pris
en otage
c'est un super gars connaît par des
millions de n'importe quoi mais c'est
long accuser nos campagnes de ces
notions une opération marketing organisé
par son équipe ça n'avait rien de saint
serge savard et c'est fake je ne
comprends pas qu à skhira coudray se
soit livré à une conclusion je vous le
donne mais tout était faux mais qu'est
ce que tu racontes comme conneries plus
ou moins j'ai longuement et maintenant
mais n'importe quoi une opération de
marketing heures mais qu'est ce tu
racontes quand les artistes viennent il
faut tous leurs promos et là au moins à
stromae la proposer quelque chose et il
a dit au moins je vais chanter rue
levert il a eu au moins le courage de
faire ce qu'il a fait sur les 21 perçu
dit n'importe quoi elles mêmes
alors tu sais quoi tu es comme les
connards qui viennent dire aussi les
hommes politiques c'est pas le lieu pour
faire tnp bad en fait tu dis la même
chose c'est exact souvent le lieu si on
attend on peut changer aujourd'hui le jt
de tf1 et le risque qu'ils ont pris moi
je dis bravo à tf1 là dessus et un bravo
à l'information tête un bravo anne
claire coudray moi je vais vous dans le
monde à vie c'est ça et bravo à stromae
aux équipes ont fait un super content
mais qu'on s'attendait pas à ça et que
mine de rien ce truc c'est un super
spectacle dans le jt de 20 heures une
opération marketing tu crois que quand
un acteur toi quand un acteur un
chanteur andré il vient dans une
émission 3 qui l'attend pas qu'on passe
c'est vrai sa bande annonce vo - stromae
il a dit moi je vais proposer un truc je
vais chanter sur les débiteurs sur ces
questions là il fait semblant de nous
apporter une chambre n'avait pas du tout
mais quand même mais dis pas de bêtises
les téléspectateurs ils sont pas bêtes
qu'ils savent très bien que tout a été
répété c'est normal je commençais à se
mettre à chanter comme ça at-il mais tu
crois quoi pourquoi dépenses jusqu'à ou
gîtes -puisque quand on dit et il ya des
acteurs qui viennent faire la prière
autre chose pour faire la promotion
c'est vraiment il est au contraire et
l'a déchue chanteur laissez moi faire un
morceau de même en plus vous achetez le
trou que c'était super bien fait avec la
question oui on peut le voir l'extrait
comme seul s'il vous plaît merci si l'on
sur kino dans vos chansons parler aussi
beaucoup de solitude est ce que la
musique vous a aidé à vous en libérer
je suis pas tout seul à être tout seul
ça fait déjà ça de moins dans la tête et
si je comptais combien on est
beaucoup tout ce à quoi je vais déjà
pensé dire que plein d'autres y ont déjà
pensé mais malgré tout je me sens tout
seul
du coup
j'ai parfois eu des pensées suicidaires
et j'en suis fier on croit parfois que
c'est la seule manière de les faire
d'être merci stromae pour ce si beau
canaux merci à vous pour votre accueil
de mardor géraldine son retour il y aura
10 mai le bon bout de libération n'a pas
aimé le mauvais goût de tf1 ça nous fait
une belle jambe moi je trouve que pour
le coup c'est un génie c'est un maestro
il déconstruit justement la proposition
du journal de 20 heures j'ai trouvé ça
extraordinaire ils étaient reçus il ya
quinze jours chez jimmy fallon tout le
monde crie au génie et là c'est sur tf1
on va se boucher le nez sont séparés
texte voilà c'est justement une
invention il propose une promo
différemment moi j'ai trouvé que c'était
super bien fait on quand michel serrault
il se déshabille c'est dû marquer bien
sûr qu'en analysant les gants de boxe à
tapis à le pen c'est du marketing à sion
arrêtez d'être des naïfs comme ça tous
sont sous-entendus voilà c'est sur tf1
donc forcément c'est pas bien
franchement c'est à sa demande le
voulait ce qui est gênant dans cette île
dernier ce que pointe libération c'est
les coulisses de l'interview en fait
comme la question là c'est quoi alors
donnez nous vos données ou valence que
des libérations en gros c'est que la
question posée par guerre coudray avant
sa performance est évidemment préparé ce
qui est normal quand on sait nous en
tant que toutes les interviews étaient
préparés validé par stromae quelque part
tf1 un peu perdu son indépendance
éditoriale hier soir avec eux des
questions
l'image de pompes pendant un quart
d'heure et ça a pas sa place sur ajouter
le terrain mais qu'est ce tu racontes du
cirage de pompes baissière les pompes à
toulouse c'est au pas sur les autres
invités ils ont des questions un peu
plus polémiques là c'est normal
attendez attendez sio paix ils ont des
questions polémiques hotz et des hommes
politiques bien daniel auteuil qui vient
on lui dit alors daniel auteuil ton film
c'est de la merde
là mais tout vient des retards au
tournant avec les extraterrestres
médina peur de quoi
cm c'est incroyable venir l'économie et
les deux là sont des benjamins c'est
votre fils ou quoi mais non
non mais ça leur met son écot dallas
mais sans déconner tu le vois le mec est
maniaque stromae étaient dessus tu as
déjà vu le jt de 20h de tf1 qui veut
dire moi j'ai entendu et écouté votre
album c'est pas fou c'est pas tant la
5ème éteinte à
mes questions mais je vous dire quelles
questions polémiques il a sorti son
single il ya un peu plus d'un mois un
mois et demi on l'a plus vu plus entendu
pendant un mois et demi pourquoi voilà
c'est la question qu'il joue sur cette
question polémique baisser le maire
s'est il emballé mais là ya du dos a
laissé des mois votre album est sorti il
ya un moyen de vous après trois ans et
demi
personne comme les mecs ses bourreaux
merci 1la excusez moi de vous dire
voudrais d énorme connerie même si je
vous aime beaucoup la et des questions
polémiques sur le jt de 20 heures n'est
pas ce qu'on avait déjà vu allez
réveiller vous avez déjà vu ça mais non
c'est pas une interview de critiques de
cinéma ou de critique de musique là
c'est une interview enfin minutes de jt
on sait très bien à chaque fois qu'on va
recevoir tu peux te parle dans le cadre
de scud mois kg 1 on va on va recevoir
des gens qui vont viennent faire leur
promo et on vient pas les pitot ces
citoyens n'étaient que c'est autre chose
mais surtout ce qui est embêtant c'est
un exil qui vous a donné la parole qui
vous
claque je ne crois plus je ne crois plus
de voir la demande est
justement n'avait plus a demandé n'avez
plus la voir aussi commerci ce film est
justement c'est pour ça on comprend pas
le journal libération parce que ça c'est
un modèle de libération et des libres et
les originales il propose des choses il
va vraiment de l'avant et en même temps
il parle d'un sujet hyper tabou qu'est
les idées noires dans un monde où sur
instagram tout le monde va bien qu'est
le suicide où tout le monde va pas bien
sur instagram sur instagram c'est quand
même très jeune mais bon c'est avant
tout une vie il ya beaucoup qui disent
qu'ils vont mal aussi sur un steinway
enfin qui le quittent quand ils vont mal
aussi vous vous gagnez sur instagram au
paddle
[Applaudissements]
vous avez tort stromae mais sur le
naufrage
[Musique]
je le vois je vois arriver la semaine
alors oui allez on passe on passe à
castaldi que la performance de l'artiste
est magnifique c'est vraiment courageux
et ça c'est du libé tout craché que tout
le monde aime il faut il faut le
démonter le dézinguer sénat voilà merci
en tout cas très bien
ils sont l'une est d'une mauvaise foi
totale libération tous les dimanches
soir dans le jt de france 2 laurent
delahousse reçoit des artistes alors
leur dresse le tapis rouge est une
filiale à y vendre à dimanche soit la
raison le jt dont il
s'agit mais lisez pas libération je ne
savais pas pourquoi il ya maintenant je
sais pourquoi je ne suis ravi de pâlir
sillage un texto d'isabelle elle a fait
une belle intervention la [ __ ]
[Rires]
excusez moi ce qu est ce qu a dit daniel
mais non mais daniel prouve absolument
que guillaume et moi avons raison c'est
à dire que chez delahousse est identifié
magasin tati presque divertissement
alors classé dans le coeur du journal et
ses sacs et tf1 s'est vendu corps et
biens et amos y ont plus à stromae ça ça
me gêne c'est f1 n'a pas à se soumettre
au diktat de monsieur la roma